1 I 2000 17 uhr 1 oder
Murat wie das mysteriöse objekt
Aus dem interstellaren raum mittlerweile als der brocken hat die form eines schwerst
Kenneth also einem raumschiff und der gilt als wirkliche sensation jetzt hat ein forschungsteam aus irland neue erkenntnisse zu seiner zusammensetzung
Ob das rätsel um seine identität jetzt endgültig gelöst ist und
inwieweit aliens in der neuen theorie eine rolle spielen jetzt in klink zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Vor ein paar tagen haben wir erst berichtet ein forschungsteam der initiative breakthrough listen hatte eine große aktion gestartet mit dem radioteleskop
Wollten sie den mysteriösen brocken über mehrere frequenzen abhören wo kommt humor her woraus besteht der sendete, er signale
außerirdischer intelligenz aber es blieb alles ruhig bislang zumindest doch das ändert nichts daran
humor bleibt mehr als mysteriös und
forschungsteams weltweit suchen fieberhaft nach neuen erkenntnissen oder zumindest hinweisen um seine identität
Zu klären denn es sind mehr fragen offen als beantwortet fest steht nur es handelt sich um das erste
interstellare objekt das nicht aus unserem sonnensystem stammt und dessen durchflug wir beobachten konnten schätzungen zufolge
Soll das etwa ein mal. Im jahr passieren dass
Also ein interstellarer besucher unser sonnensystem durchquert um nur moore ist der erste der eindeutig
identifiziert werden konnte wegen ihm gibt es jetzt eine neue kategorie der internationalen astronomischen union ii für
Interstellar das seltsame der brocken besteht wohl nicht aus gas und also wie wir sonst von kometen aus unserem sonnensystem
Kennt denn sonst hätte
Er ja verdampfen müssen als er am 19 september
2017 an unserer sonne vorbei geflogen ist um
Moore sei ein einfacher gesteinsbrocken sowie ein ass en ihn sagt jetzt ein forschungsteam von der queen's university in belfast
entstanden sei er aus den grundbaustein aller planeten kleine partikel kondensieren
Im weltall und heften sich aneinander erst zu winzigen klümpchen dann, zu großen brocken in der fachsprache bleibt
Nähte sie male genannt also quasi so etwas wie das rohmaterial für planeten
Humor habe allerdings eine isolierende schutzschicht bestehend
Aus kohlenstoff verbindung diese hat nach angaben des forschungsteams eine gewisse ähnlichkeit mit den objekten die sich, am rand unseres sonnensystems
befinden und eben auch mit
kohle stoff
Reiche mais bedeckt sind und das ist echt eine überraschung sagt auch eine der beteiligten forscherinnen mit kälbern ist
Es ist faszinierend dass das erste entdeckte interstellare objekt so sehr wie eine winzige welt aus unserem eigenen
heimat system anmutet entstanden sei die küste von humor bei seiner reise durch den weltraum und dem beschuss von
Kosmischer strahlung genau diese kruste schütze dem brocken jetzt gegen die hitze sonne und was wir sonst noch über ihn wissen
Humor ist rund zehnmal so lang wie er breit ist das teleskop an stars auf hawaii hatte ihm jahr am 19 oktober entdeckt
Er kam aus der richtung, des sterns wega, im sternbild leier
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes von oben senkrecht zu den umlaufbahnen zwischen sonne und merkur bahn
Zudem verhält er sich wirklich ziemlich spooky es rot wird mal heller mal dunkler messungen haben ergeben dass
Er seine helligkeit, um den faktor 10 verändert
zudem rotiert der wohl das ist das ergebnis dieser helligkeits veränderungen wohl alle 73 stunden
Um seine eigene achse zurück zu den neuesten erkenntnissen demnach ist humor also ein natürliches objekt und das bremst natürlich die hoffnung darauf
gleich in diesem zusammenhang doch noch hinweise auf
außerirdisches leben zu entdecken doch die forschungsteams geben nicht auf denn die bereits gesammelten daten von humor
Sind noch lange nicht alle analysiert also doch ein raumschiff sowie auch ihr es schon
spekuliert hatte die chance stehen
Ehrlich gesagt schlecht aber wir bleiben dran wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollte hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken eine sensation
interstellare objekt rast durchs sonnensystem mit allen weiteren infos humor also ansonsten bisher
bleibt kann